My name is Daniel Felt,
and I am the owner of Kura Home.
Today, we are going to
go through the process
of deep cleaning air ducts.
The purpose of an air duct is essentially
to provide fresh, clean air to your home.
We provide air-duct cleaning
and routine home-maintenance services
where we visit our clients'
homes once a quarter
and do everything you're
supposed to be doing
as a perfect homeowner
but a lot of people don't have the time
or neglect to do.
When we clean the air ducts,
we go through and we
clean the entire system.
So we start in the upper level,
and we work our way all the
way through the entire home.
Depending on who and what
is living in the home,
the debris that we find
inside of air ducts
consists of a lot of different items,
such as skin cells, dust,
dander, pet debris, pet hair.
Anything that you would see when you
maybe wipe your feet off on a rug
when you walk inside a home
can be found inside of an air duct.
This air duct has not been cleaned
for probably 50-plus years.
Additionally, the person
that lived in this home
has also smoked and had pets.
So this is a very severe air duct
that you can actually smell it.
It has a old-house smell
built up over time.
If it's a really light color,
often we're finding
sawdust or Sheetrock dust
that is from construction debris.
As we get into darker colors,
sometimes smoking inside the home
is going to leave more of a yellow color.
And as it gets darker, a lot of times
we're more concerned
about a humidity issue
that can eventually turn
into a dark-colored mold.
You're getting into more
hazardous material in there.
Once the air-duct cover is removed,
we are going to allow
the air-compressor hose
to be put into the air duct.
Before we're turning on that hose,
we're going to put a
clear dome over the cover
and we're going to attach
our HEPA vacuum to the dome.
Once those items are in place,
we're going to turn the air compressor on,
and that allows the hose
with a reverse-blasting ball
to propel itself forward
into the air duct.
The clear dome that's used is crucial
because it creates a sealed environment
so that we're getting all the dust
and debris out of the home and we're not
creating a mess inside the home.
But it's also crucial because it creates
a really nice suction area.
So all of the power
from the air compressor
and the vacuum are working together
to pull and push the debris outside.
We can twist and turn that hose,
so we can go around any corner.
Once we get to the end trunk line,
we can feel that in the
air-compressor hose,
and we're going to slowly pull that back
at about 1 foot per second.
As we're doing that,
we can see all the dust
and debris that is being
removed from the air duct
come through that clear dome
and go into the HEPA vacuum.
Once we've completed the cleaning,
we find that a little
bit of dust and debris
has come all the way at
the end of the air duct.
And it's really important
to take your vacuum
and clean out that extra
debris that's come.
Oftentimes, that's where
you're going to find
the real treasures, such as bugs, toys,
dog toys, bones, items like that
that have been placed
really far into the air duct
and all of our equipment
has pulled it out.
In order to clean the dust and debris
that's found on the inside
or outside of vents,
you want to remove the vent first
and brush that off with the vacuum,
and you're going to get a majority
of dust and debris off.
Then we put the vent cover back on
and replace the screws
back to the original format
and make sure the area is nice and clean
and clear of debris.
All the air in your home is circulating
through your furnace on a regular basis.
And by having a clean,
clear furnace filter,
it's going to catch
all the dust and debris
that is circulating throughout.
Depending on the style of
furnace filter that you have,
you may have one that needs to be cleaned
on a regular basis, and you can do this
by using a HEPA vacuum and brush.
Locate the furnace filter
inside your furnace
and remove that door and
pull that furnace filter out.
The next thing you want
to do is take your vacuum
and place that over the furnace filter
to make sure you're cleaning that
really nice and thoroughly.
A dryer vent is allowing
the exhaust from a dryer
to be pushed outside of the home.
The reason why is because, over time,
lint builds up inside that dryer vent.
To properly clean a dryer vent,
usually you just need an air compressor,
and you can use a
reverse-blasting ball or whip
to place inside the dryer vent.
We're going to find that exhaust
on the outside of the home,
and we're going to place
the air-compressor hose
inside the dryer vent,
and we're going to turn that on.
That will propel itself into the dryer
and dislodge all of the lint
that's built up over time.
There's heat that's being pushed
through that dryer vent,
and if the dryer vent does
not have proper airflow,
it's very easy for that lint
to become flammable and start on fire.
We recommend having
your dryer vent cleaned
on an annual basis to prevent
the buildup of the lint
and decrease the chance of a
fire happening in your home.
Depending on your current health,
such as if you have really
bad allergies or not,
that can play a really large factor
on the risk of living in a home
with the dirty air ducts.
We've had all kinds of different results.
We've had people that have told us
that they slept through the
night for the first time
after they had their air ducts cleaned,
because the air quality
was improved that much.